[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من العربيه وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن توصل لاتفاق يوقف
النار في السودان لاربع وعشرين ساعه بدايه
من صباح الغد
كاتب امريكي ايراني يدعو واشنطن لفهم ولي
العهد السعودي وبدء مرحله جديده مع الرياض
رحله السعوديه نحو ثوره الصناعيه الرابعه
تستمر تقيم مئه مصنع وتضاعف اعداد
العاملين
قام بملفات الرابعه ايضا
وحنان القرشي تتراس نادي ويج في محافظه
الطائف اول سيده سعوديه تتولى رئاسه نادي
رياضي
حياكم الله البدايه من السودان حيث اعلنت
الخارجيه السعوديه عن اتفاق بين الجيش
والدعم السريع لوقف النار لمده 24 ساعه
يبدا من صباح السبت واكدت السعوديه
وامريكا في بيان مشترك انه في حال عدم
التزام طرفي الصراع فسيكونان مضطرين
بصفتهما ميسرين للحوار تاجيل المحادثات في
جده واكد انهما يشاركان الشعب السوداني
حاله الاحباط جراء عدم الالتزام بالهدن
السابقه
قبل ذلك وخلال خطاب القاه بين جنوده في
القوات المسلحه اكد نائب قائد الجيش
السوداني شمس الدين كباشي ان قوات الجيش
متماسكه وان قوات الدعم السريع تنشر
الاكاذيب مشيرا الى ان البرهان يقود
المعارك على الارض
[موسيقى]
هو البدير المعرفه مع هيئه القياده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الهزام
معتقل القائد الفلان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كلنا ميتون
تكذب تقول صفقه الجيش منقسم على نفسه
والجيش وكذا وكذا
من لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني خالد العيسى السيد خالد مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض هل يمكن ان
يلتزم طرفي الصراع هذه المره بما تم
الاتفاق عليه مع ميسري الحوار في جده
م الكرام لا ريب ان كل الاطراف في السودان
الان تزعلي للحصول على هدنه
منضبطه الى حد كبير لكي تسمح بمرور
المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيبيه
للمواطنين في مدينه الخرطوم درمان وبحري
على وجه الخصوص وحتى مدن السودان الاخرى
ولكن بالتاكيد بالنظر الى الهدن السابقه
يجب ان تكون هذه ان تتبع هذه الهدنه افعال
وليس اقوال باعتبار ان المخالفات التي تمت
في الماضي والانتهاكات التي ارتكبت قوات
الدعم السريع كانت تشكل عقبه اساسيه في
تنفيذ كل الهدن السابقه هي ظلت توقع
اتفاقات في جده وفي السعوديه ولكنها لا
توفي بشروط الاتفاقات ظلت في ازاله
الاماكن في المستشفيات في المراكز الطبيه
في المنازل زلت تعطل حركه مرور المساعدات
الانسانيه هذا بشهاده منظمه الصحه
العالميه التي ذكرت ان قوات الدعم السريع
قطعت الطريق امام مساعدات او واصله من
بورسودان وبالتالي يجب هنا الالتزام بهذه
الهدنه على اقل تقدير لاثبات حسن النوايا
الان الشعب السوداني يريد نوع من الهدن
التي تسمح بمرور المساعدات وهذه بالضروره
لها علاقه لها بالملفات السياسيه والامنيه
العسكريه والحربيه 24 ساعه فقط هي مده
الالتزام بوقف النار هل هي اختبار للنوايا
كما ذكرت املي اسباب اخرى
بالتاكيد هي واضحه ان اختبار للنوايا لا
سيما ان هذه الساعات القليل لا يمكن ان
تسمح بمرور المساعدات لكل الاطراف البلاد
المتراميه وهذه الصراع الذي يدور في بعض
البؤره الصراع الملتهبه وبالتاكيت هي يعني
في صياغه تثبيت حسن النوايا بعد تثبيت حسن
النوايا يمكن ان ينظر في امكانيه تمديد
هذه الهدى لمراحل اكبر واوسع وبالتاكيد
الحاله العامه في السودان تحتاج الى
السماح بمرور القزازه والدواء والعلاج
للمحتاجين في العاصمه بمدون الثلاث وحتى
المدن في الاقاليم المتراميه الاطراف لا
سيما دارفور وبعض المناطق في وسط السودان
بالتاكيد كل اقاليم الشرق والشمال هي لا
الان اصبحت لا تعاني من قضايا تتصل
بالدواء ولكن ربما هناك شذف عيش ومعاناه
الى حد كبير ايضا تحتاج الى نوع من الهدن
لكن بالتاكيد كما ذكرت لك
حسن النوايا في خلال هذه الاربعه والعشرين
ساعه سيتم تاجيل المحادثات بشكل كامل كما
ذكر هذا البيان السعودي الامريكي هناك كيف
سيكون وضع السودان على المستوى العسكري
على المستوى الانساني والصحي والغذائي
وغيره
ظللنا نرد اليوم الاول ان هذه المعركه بعد
قرارات القائد العام التي طالبت قوات
الدعم السريع بضروره وضع السلاح جانب
الانضمام الى المؤسسه العسكريه فيما عرف
بالعفو الذي اصدر وهو حتى مصدر قرارات
تشير الى النقوات حرس الحدود ستكون الوعاء
الجديد لاستيعاب كل القوى الوطنيه في حركه
في قوات الدعم السريع لا سيما اولئك
السودانيون من الاساس هناك في كوادر
اجنبيه سبت بالدليل القاطع وفق بيانات
الجيش وشهادات دول الجوار ان هناك عناصر
اجنبيه لن يكون لها موتي قدم في اي معادله
سياسيه تستوعب هذه الكوادر التي تنتسب الى
قوه الدعم السريع هناك عشرات الالاف انا
اكرر هذه الجمله عشرات الالاف من جنود
الدعم السريع الوطنيون الذين انضموا الى
الجيش ووضع السلاح جاربا رعب بهم الان
يعملون وفق مؤسسه الجيش وشهدنا في الشرق
السودان الالاف انضموا في جنوب كردفان وفي
دارفور وفي الابيض يعني حتى الترويج الى
النقوات الدعم السريع ازبلق ككتله هي الان
تصارع الجيش هذه خاطئه يجب ان لا تمر هناك
عشرات الالوف من ابناء الشعب السوداني
الوطنيون الذين الغوا السلاح جانبا
وانضموا الى المؤسسه العسكريه اذا السؤال
لماذا تقاتل قوات الدعم السريع الان لماذا
لا تلقي السلاح وتنضم الى المؤسسه الوطنيه
الا من اجرى منهم وارتكب خروقات هي تتحدث
عن ان هناك بعض العناصر المتفلته هذه
العناصر المتفلته لا يمكن ان يكون لها
استيعاف في المؤسسه الامنيه الوطنيه
وبالتالي يجب ان يلغوا السلاح جانبا وان
يستجيبوا في حال عدم استجابتها هذه معرقه
كل الناس يعلمون وانت تعلم وكل المؤسسه
محطات التلفزه تعلم ان قوات الدعم السريع
عندما خططت لهذه العمليه كانت زهير مئات
الالاف مئه الف او ما يزيد وهيا الان لا
تعد سوى مجموعه من الالاف المتفلته في
شوارع وبعض البور الملتهبه في بعض المناطق
هي خسرت وبالتالي استمرار امد الصراع هو
بمثابه المحرقه لهذه القوات وهذا مصير
حتمه لم يستجيبوا لكلمه
الصحفيه السوداني خالد الراعي
دعا مقال نشرته واشنطن تايمز للكاتب
الايراني الامريكي والبروفيسور في جامعه
جورج تاون روب سبحاني دعا صناع سياسه في
الولايات المتحده للبحث عن شركاء اقوياء
في مواجهه التحديات العالميه واعتبر
الكاتب ان الشركه الامثل الذي يجب على
امريكا ان تتعاون معه هو ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان مؤكدا انه
محفز بدوافع ايجابيه لخلق نهضه سعوديه
جديده الكاتب في مقاله ذكر بان فهم ما
يحفز ولي العهد السعودي يشكل نقطه البدايه
لكيفيه تعامل واشنطن مع قائد سيلعب دورا
مهما على المسرح العالمي لسنوات قادمه
المقال اختصر ما وصفه بالدوافع التي تحرك
الامير محمد بن سلمان بخمسه دوافع اولها
حبه وفخره بالسعوديه وشعبها بالاضافه الى
رغبته في ترك ارتيل لبلاده خصوصا في ظل ان
60% من السكان هم تحت سن الثلاثين من
الدوافع ايضا بحسب المقال رغبه ولي العهد
السعودي في جعل بلاده قوه للتغيير
الايجابي على الساحه العالميه
من واشنطن ينضم الينا البحث في الشؤون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباسيه
ايهاب مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذا المقال في واشنطن سبقه زياره
ولقاء لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع الامير
محمد بن سلمان عهد السعودي لاي مدى هنا
استشعرت هذه الاداره الامريكيه اهميه
علاقاتها مع السعوديه وعلى وجه الخصوص مع
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
في خارطه سياستها الخارجيه
سيدي ايهاب
طيب
اهلا بحضرتك استاذ نايف اعتذر
اهلا بالمشاهدين اسمح لي اضيف على ما قاله
الكاتب الايراني نقطه مهمه ايضا
اضافيه وهي ان
البعد المهم جدا الذي اضافه ايضا الامير
محمد بن سلمان هو رؤيته للاقليم واحداثه
من من الممكن ان تنتج عنه من
من الشر او خير للاقليم وبالتالي هذه
الرؤيه ايضا هي التي دعت واشنطن كي تتعامل
معه لانها تعلم انه لديه رؤيه مهمه ومحفزه
للاقليم في كافه المجالات اذا ما عدنا الى
الذي
يدعوا واشنطن لتغيير سياساتها اليوم
واشنطن في الواقع خسرت الكثير خلال
السنتين الماضيتين منذ تولي الرئيس جو
بايدن اداره الولايات المتحده كانت لديها
سياسات غير واضحه المملكه انا كنت اعتبرها
سياسات استفزازيه سياسات لا ترتقي لرؤيه
حليف وشريك قوي لشريكه الاخر وحليفه القوي
ايضا وبالتالي كانت علاقات متوتره في
البدايه ودائما اقول لدينا عامل ثابت في
هذه العلاقه هو عامل متغير الثابت هو
المملكه العربيه السعوديه سياسه واضحه
قريبه فيها لا تحتاج الى اي تفسيرات
والعمل المتغير هو الاداره الامريكيه
اداره جو بايدن تاره اداره دونالد
ترامباما الى اخره العامل المتغير في
علاقه مهمه كعلاقه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ستكون دائما شيء لا يحمد عقبه بمعنى ستؤخر
الكثير من الامور المتعلقه بسياسات التي
من المفترض ان تمارسها واشنطن في المنطقه
مع حلفائها وشركائها وشاهدنا طبعا الاداره
في بدايه العلاقه عندما قام برفع مثلا
جماعه الحوثيين من قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه بخلاف ما كان وضعها قبل ذلك
دونالد ترامب في هذه القائمه واستمرار
الهجمات وبعد ذلك قال انه يدرس اعادتها
عندما قامت بتكرار هجماتها على اماكن
مدنيه ونفطيه داخل المملكه ولم يحدث اي
شيء في هذا الاطار ومع ذلك بقيت سياسه
الرياض دائما سياسه حكيمه ومتصقه مع
اهدافها المحليه
يعني الكاتب قال بان الولايات المتحده لن
يكون لها صديق وشريك نشط ايجابي وكذلك
ايضا في كثير من الملفات الدوليه العالقه
وانت تعلم حاله الانقسام وحاله الاستقطاب
الشرقيه الغربيه اليوم التي تخيم العالم
قال لن يوجد لن تجد الاداره الامريكيه
شريكا على المسرح العالمي افضل من التعامل
مع ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ما الذي دفع الكاتب برايك
لهذه الفكره
انا اعتقد طبعا الكاتب هو كاتب ايراني
معارض طبعا لايران ولديه رؤيه معينه لمن
هي الدول التي من الممكن ان تشكل الشراكه
الاهم للولايات المتحده خلال الفتره
القادمه وهو طبعا كاتب امريكا ايضا
فبالتالي هو يعتقد من وجهه نظره ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بما تتمتع به من
استقرار سياسي واقتصادي وعلاقات طيبه مع
كافه الاطراف على مستوى العالم علاقاتها
قويه مع روسيا علاقاتها قويه مع امريكا
علاقتها قويه مع الصين علاقاتها قويه مع
اوروبا ومع محيطها الاقليمي فليس هناك
افضل من مثل هذه التركيبه لاي دوله من
الدول كي تكون دوله قائده ورائده فعندما
تريد واشنطن ان يكون لديها علاقات قويه مع
مثل هذا النوع من الدول يجب ان تقدم
واشنطن ما يستدعي بالفعل ان تكون هذه
العلاقه قويه وبالتالي يجب ان تكون علاقه
شراكه وعلاقه تحالف بعد ذلك وانا اعتقد ان
العلاقه العلاقه ليست شراكه فقط هي شراكه
وتحالف ايضا ولكن هناك بعض المنغصات التي
تاتي تاره هنا وهناك بسبب اختلاف الادارات
وايدولوجيه الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
كله منهما لديه رؤيه مختلفه لكن يجب ان
يكون هناك دائما عوامل ثابته في هذه
العلاقه لا تتغير
وهذا هو ما تحدثت عنه العامل الثابت لدى
المملكه والمتغير لدى واشنطن الذي يؤدي
الى سياسات المتذبذبه التي نشاهد احد
الدوافع الخمسه كانت هي
الحب وفخر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وشعبها الامير محمد بن سلمان كما قال في
مقاله قال هذا الاعجاب يعبر عن غالب
المجتمع سواء تحدثت مع السعوديين في احد
الاحياء القديمه او حتى مع سائق احد
التطبيقات او الفنانين السعوديين قال لا
يملكون لا يملكون سوى الثناء والحب لهذا
القائد لقد اصبحت الرساله واضحه تتعامل
واشنطن مع زعيم شعبي ط ور علاقه عميقه مع
امته الشابه الاداره الامريكيه هل يتغير
تعاملها مع اي قائد اليوم سياسي
بحالته الشعبيه او بزعامته الشعبيه ايضا
كذلك سيدي ايهاب
والله شوفوا استاذ نايف ليس فقط السعوديين
داخل المملكه ولكن حتى السعوديين الذين
يعيشون بصفه دائمه ومستمره هنا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتقيت عدد
منهم هم ايضا فخورون بما يقدمه الامير
محمد بن سلمان
ويعتقدون ان ذلك يقود البلاد في الاتجاه
الصحيح والتطور السريع وهو ما نلاحظه
جميعا في الواقع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تشاهد عن كثب
مدى ارتباط الشعب السعودي بالتطورات التي
قدمها لهم الولي العهد السعودي محمد بن
سلمان خلال السنوات الماضيه ويعلمون انه
كلما كان هناك تقارب بين
الشعب والحاكم كلما كان هناك توحد في
الرؤيه وفي الفكره
وفناء في العمل ورغبه في التطور والنظر
الى الامام واشنطن بكل تاكيد يعني وانا
اكرر دائما في مقابلاتي ستخسر كثيرا اذا
ما حا ولت ان تعبث بهذه العلاقه التي تم
العبث بها بالفعل خلال السنتين الماضيين
الماضيتين لكن اليوم مع عوده العلاقات
بالشكل للمسار الطبيعه اعتقد انها من
الممكن ان تنطلق الى الامام بشكل ممتاز
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من واشنطن الباحث في
الشؤون الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب
عباس
رابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه بوينج اوكي ان
السعوديه شريك مهم للغايه ووجهه كبرى
لقطاع الطيران
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اكد رئيسه التنفيذي
لشركه بوينج الدكتور براند نيلسون في
تصريحاته للعربيه ان السعوديه عميل مهم
بالنسبه للشركه وشريك ايضا مؤكدا التزام
شركه الكامل بدعم السعوديه لتحقيق رؤيه
البلاد 203
العربيه السعوديه عميل مهم للغايه بالنسبه
لنا وهي شريك ايضا في شركه بوينج نحن
ملتزمون بالكامل بدعم المملكه وصاحب سمو
الملكي من اجل تحقيق رؤيه 2030
اعتقد ان السياق المهم هنا هو ان 32 مليون
مسافر سافروا على الخطوط الجويه السعوديه
وطيران اديل في عام 2019
توقعاتنا حسب طموحات السعوديه التي ندعمها
هو انه بحلول عام 2030 فان شركات طيران
السعوديه ستنقل 100 مليون سائح الى
المملكه
مليون مسافر دول الشرق الاوسط وبشكل خاص
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تركز بشكل اساسي
في الطائرات التي تطلبها على الطائرات ذات
الهيكل العريض
تصريحات الرئيس تنفيذي لشركه بوينج جاءت
بعد الاعلان عن تفاصيل الاسطول الجويه
لشركه طيران الرياض الزميل الشهاده
المتروك تعرفون على الاثر الذي سيتركه
الناقل الجوي السعودي الجديد خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بتوفير الوظائف نشاهد
اسطول ضخم وهويه سعوديه خالصه ملامح
الناقل الجديد
طيران بدات تتضح بعد الاعلان عن هويته
مؤخرا مئه وجهه عالميه سيصل اليها الناقل
السعودي من والى الرياض بحلول العام 2030
كم من الوظائف سيوفرها طيران الرياض من
التاسيس الى التشغيل مرورا بوجهاته المئه
الف فرصه عمل مباشره وغير مباشره يستهدف
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه خلقها عبر طيران
الرياض الذي سيغير وجه النقل الجوي في
المنطقه والعالم هل تريد الانضمام لشركه
طيران الرياض بامكانك الان زياره الموقع
الرسمي واستعراض الوظائف الشاغره والتقديم
عليها وفقا للمتطلبات الموضحه على الموقع
وهي الطريقه الوحيده للحصول على وظيفه قد
تغير حياتك
مجالات متعدده حددها طيران الرياض
لاستقطاب بالكفاءات منها علوم الطيران
والهندسه وتجربه الضيوف فضلا عن التقنيه
وتخصصات الاداره العامه اكثر من 300 الف
طلب عمل تلقته شركه طيران الرياض حتى الان
من
182 دوله عدد هائل يؤكد ان العاصمه
السعوديه ستكون وجهه مفضله للعمل لجميع
الجنسيات
الطريق نحو بناء واحده من اهم شركات
الطيران الرائده في جميع انحاء العالم
يتطلب شراكات استراتيجيه ضمن منظومه طيران
العالميه هذا ما اكده محافظ صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه ياسر رميان مؤخرا
في السعوديه اربعه اعوام مرت على اطلاق
برنامج تطوير صناعه الوطنيه والخدمات
اللوجستيه في السعوديه ندلب سنوات حقق من
خلالها البرنامج اجمالي استثمارات يصل الى
456 مليار ريال في قطاعاته الاربعه في ظل
نمو ملحوظ لاجمال صادرات السعوديه غير
النفطيه التي وصلت الى 435 مليار ريال
وبزياده تقدر بنحو 38% في العام الماضي
مقارنه ب 2021 وفي سياق تركيز ادلب على
محور الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه قامت الهيئه
السعوديه للمدن الصناعيه مدن بتقييم مئه
مصنع وتقديم خارطه طريق لتبني التقنيات
الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه وتحفيز تبني
تقنيات الاساسيه والمتقدمه لدى 37 مشاه
هنا في الاستديو سليمان المزروع رئيس
التنفيذي لبرنامج التطوير الصناعه الوطنيه
والخدمات اللوجستيه ادلب حياك الله سعاده
المهندس مانع شكرا اخوي نايف الله يحييك
في ظل مشهد تحول وتغير كبير على مستوى
رؤيه 2030 انتصف الطريق الان ما الذي تحقق
حتى الان في ندل منذ انطلاق البرنامج وحتى
اليوم فيما يخص التحول على مستوى القطاعات
الاربعه الصناعه التعدين الخدمات
اللوجستيه ان شاء الله
في الحقيقه اسمح لي قبل ما ابدا في قطاعات
البرنامج اتكلم كيف رؤيه المملكه العشرين
قاعد تحقق هذه الانجازات اللي تشوفها وش
الاساسيات اللي بنيت عليها اهم ثلاث
اساسيات ممكن نطرحها لساعدتنا الوصول لهذه
الانجازات اللي نشوفها اولها ايمان قياده
الملهمه بابنائه وبناتها لتحقيق هذه
الطموحات العاليه اثنين شموليتها شموليه
هذه الرؤيه لتغطيه جميع احتياجات المواطن
من اسكان تنميه بشريه مصادر نمو وغيرها من
احتياجات المواطن وكذلك الشراكه مع القطاع
الخاص القطاع العام القطاع غير ربحي
المواطن المواطن المقيم جميع من يستطيع
المشاركه في هذه الاهتمام البركه 2030
يقدر يشارك فيها والحمد لله
اخر نقطه وهي طموحات المملكه هي صحيح
للسعوديين لكنها تشارك في المجتمع الدولي
وجميع طموحاته نتكلم عن سد ثغرات سلاسل
الامداد ربط القارات تقديم صناعات معرفيه
تطور الانسان والمجتمع العالمي فهذا ما
جعلها رؤيه مباركه للسعوديين والعالم
الجميع حنا في برنامج تطوير صناعه
والوطنيه والخدمات اللوجستيه ندلب معنيين
بتنويع مصادر النمو في اربع قطاعات حيويه
صناعه وتعديل والطاقه والخدمات اللوجستيه
نطمح باذن الله نكون قوه صناعيه رائده
ومنصه لاجستي عالميه باذن الله في عشرين
الحديث دائما عن العوائد الاقتصاديه حتى
الان سواء اللي جات بشكل مباشر او التي
جاءت بشكل غير مباشر يعني على على
البرنامج وعلى هذه القطاعات الاربعه اللي
موجوده فيه وكمان ايضا في محورين ارتكاز
ايضا في في البرنامج
بلا شك البرنامج برنامج اقتصادي ومقاييسه
ومؤشراته هي اقتصاديه ايضا لدينا اول مؤشر
وهو الناتج المحلي المملكه حققت الحمد لله
في 2022
الاعلى نموا من خلال مجموعه العشرين وهذا
يعتبر رقم عالي من الاسرع نمون على مستوى
العالم ومستوى مجموعه العشرين
الصادرات الغير نفطيه حققنا اكثر من 435
مليار وهو يتضاعف عن ما كنا عليه قبل رؤيه
قبل رؤيه تقريبا في عام 2016 تقريبا 242
الان نتكلم عن 435
صناعه يعني صناعات جديده وصادرات غير
نفطيه جديده دخلت في المزيج صادرات غير
نفطيه الحمد لله كذلك الاستثمارات حققنا
ما يقارب ال500 مليار استثمارات منذ بدايه
البرنامج وهذا الرقم عالي جدا لكن يدل على
زياده جاذبيه هذه القطاعات
للمستثمرين سواء في الصناعه الطاقه في
التعديل او الخدمات القطاعات الاربعه
باجيها بس خلني اتكلم على اول قطعين اللي
هي الطاقه والتعديل خلينا نبدا فيها هي من
القطاعات الاربعه التنفيذيه وش اللي تحقق
فيها والملفت ايضا كذلك في هذا القطاعين
قطاع الطاقه هو قطاع ريادي على مستوى
المملكه والعالم بقياده سمو وزير الطاقه
عراب الطاقه ودبلوماسية اذا بركز على
نقطتين التقرير مليء بالانجازات لكن
نقطتين مهمتين اولها تحول للطاقه المتجدده
عندنا في 2022 الحمد لله اكثر من ترسيه
اكثر من اربع مشاريع وطرح اكثر من خمس
مشاريع نتكلم عن مجمل 21 مليار ريال من
المشاريع للطاقه المتجدده كذلك التوطين
صناعات المرتبطه بالنفط الغاز وصلنا الى
اكثر من 63% وهذا رقم عالي جدا في مثل هذه
الصناعات الصعبه وتوطينها يحتاج الى جهود
الحمد لله بجهود الجهات التنفيذيه وشراكه
خلاص تم تحقيقها
في ايضا قطاع الصناعه والخدمات اللوجستيه
شهدت كانت نقله نوعيه كبيره عندما تمت
الاعلان عن الاستراتيجيات الوطنيه
المرتبطه فيها واللي تحققت في 2022
بالاضافه ايضا كذلك
ردتها على الاستثمارات واعلى المصانع اخر
شيء طبعا احنا نقيسها من خلال ما نراه من
صندوق التنميه الصناعي الاقراض اللي يصير
تقريبا اكثر من 14 مليار في 22 وهذا يدل
على زياده في عام واحد في عام واحد اكثر
من 14 مليار كذلك من ناحيه تصدير شفنا
التسهيلات الائتمانيه اللي قدمها بنك
التصدير واستيراد واللي هي تقريبا اكثر من
14 بوينت 14.6 مليار من التسهيلات
التامينيه اللي صارت في
الصادرات السعوديه الغير نفضيه طبعا
وارتباط او الخدمات اللوجستيه ايضا
الخدمات اللجديه والتعدين يعتبرون من
القطاعات الواعده في المملكه اللي بدات مع
رؤيه المملكه 2030 تاخذ اهتمام الكبير من
القياده الملهمه اول باكلم شوي عن
اللاجستيه وكذلك عن التعدين القطاع
اللوجستي شفناه ست منصات لجستيه في
الموانع جديده منطقه لوجستيه خاصه في مطار
الملك خالد جابت لنا استثمارات مثل ابل في
مطار في منطقه اللوجستيه في مطار الملك
خالد قفزنا اكثر من 17 مرتبه في مؤشر صادر
من البنك الدولي لاداء الخدمات اللوجستيه
كذلك راينا زياده في
اعاده تصدير والمسافنه بارقام قياسيه
موجوده في
التقرير لمن اراد الاستيازه فيها ارقام
اللوجستيه بدينا نشوف بدايه نجاحاتها في
20 22 الحمد لله من ناحيه التعدين حقيقه
كذلك واحد القطاعات الواعده واللي بدا مع
رؤيه المملكه 2030 بعد استراتيجيته وتنظيم
القطاع
بالاستثمار فيه شفناه ايرادات غير نفطيه
هي الاعلى على مستوى تاريخ القطاع تقريبا
اكثر من 95% من محققه في 21 حققها في 22
شفنا رخصتين استكشاف رخصه الاستكشاف شراكه
مع القطاع الخاص لاستكشاف الخناقيه ومن
الدمار وخمسه وعشرين بالم ئه تم الحمد لله
استكشافها من الدر العربي اللي في عائد
كثير على الاقتصاد السعودي
المهندس سليمان المزروع رئيس التنفيذي
لبرنامج تطوير الصناعه الوطنيه والخدمات
اللوجستيه بشكل جزيلا
الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
ترقب لاعصار جديد على سواحل عمان وتحذيرات
من تاثيراته التي قد تمتد لاربعه ايام
قادمه
[تصفيق]
الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن التوصل الاتفاق
يوقف النار في السودان لاربع وعشرين ساعه
بدايه من صباح الغد
كاتب امريكي ايراني يدعو واشنطن لفهم ولي
العهد السعودي بدا مرحله جديده مع الرياض
رحله السعوديه نحو الثوره الصناعيه
الرابعه تستمر تقييم مئه مصنع وتضاعف
اعداد العاملين
ترقب لاعثار جديد على سواحل عمان وتحذيرات
من تاثيرات التي قد تمت قد تمتد لاربعه
ايام قادمه
وحنان القرشي تتراس نادي وجه في محافظه
الطائف اول سيده سعوديه تتولى رئاسه نادي
الرياضي
حياكم الله من جديد نذهب لمشاهده هذه
الصور من لقاء الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون بعائلات الضحايا في هجوم مدينه
انسي هذا الهجوم الذي لا قائدانات دوليه
واسعه كان الرئيس ماكرون قد وصل الى مدينه
جرونوبل جنوب شرق البلاد حيث نقل ثلاثه
اطفال من الاربعه الذين اصيبوا امس خلال
هجوم بسكين في مدينه انسي ماكرون يقول بان
صحه الاطفال الذين تعرضوا
لهجوم في انسي جيده لا تزال طبعا السلطات
الفرنسيه تحقق في دوافع منفذ الهجوم وهو
لاجئ سوري لكن المدعيه الفرنسيه العامه
لينبونيه اشارت امس الى ان دوافع الرجل
مجهوله
ولكن يبدو انها غير مرتبطه بالارهاب كما
قالت الرئيس ماكرون اذا يقول بان صحه
الاطفال الذين تعرضوا الهجوم في انسي جيده
هذا الهجوم الذي نفذه لاجئ كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل لاجئ سوري اصيب في هذا الهجوم
سته اشخاص او خمسه اشخاص بينهم اربعه
اطفال يتحدث الان الرئيس الفرنسي
الذي وصل الى
هذه المدينه مدينه انسي يتحدث بان صحه
الاطفال الذين تعرضوا للهجوم في انسي حتى
هذه اللحظه جيده تحدث الان اماما الرئيس
الفرنسي ايميل
ماكرون اذا عن هذه الحادثه والتي كما
ذكرنا بانها لاقت ادانات دوليه واسعه بعد
هذه العمليه والاعتداء الوحشي بالقرب طبعا
من نافوره انسي الشهيره في هذه المدينه
اذا
يصل الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ويؤكد
بان صحه من تعرضوا لهجوم الى الاطفال في
انسي جيده حتى الان
من هذا المكان قفز المعتدي وهو يصرخ بكلام
غير مفهوم نحو مدخل الحديقه التي كان
يتنزه فيها عدد من السياح والسكان
المحليين كان هناك اطفال داخل عرباتهم
يحرسهم ذووهم انقض المعتدي بسكين على طفل
هولندي يبلغ من العمر 22 شهرا
ثم على طفل بريطاني في عامه الثاني ثم على
طفلين شقيقين فرنسيين هم اخ في الثانيه من
عمره واخته في الثالثه من عمرها كما اصيب
بجراح خطره رجل مسن واخر اقل سنا اصيب
ايضا ولكن بجراح طفيفه المعتدي لا يتعاون
مع الشرطه حتى الان
وقد قال تطلقته التي اتصلت بها احدى وسائل
الاعلام انه مسيحي سوري من مدينه الحسكه
تحديدا كان تقدم بطلبات اللجوء في كل من
ايطاليا وسويسرا والسويد وقبلت طلبات
اللجوء كلها ثم اصر على طلب اللجوء في
فرنسا لكن طلب اللجوء هنا رفض في السادس
والعشرين من لسان ابريل الماضي وقد ابلغ
المعتدي بهذا الرفض قبل اربعه ايام من
ارتكاب جريمته فهل يكون هناك بل تكون هناك
علاقه بين هذا الرفض وبين الجريمه سؤال
سيجيب عنه التحقيق المتواصل الذي سيجيب
ايضا على اسئله اخرى كثيره حسين قنيبر
للعربيه والحدث من مدينه انسي فرنسا
اعصار جديد تترقبه السواحل العمانيه وبحر
العرب وسط تحذيرات المشدده حيث اوضحت
الارصاد الجويه العمانيه ان الاعصار يبعد
الان عن سواحل السلطنه 1020 كيلو متر
وحذرت السلطات في عمان من ارتفاع امواج
البحر الى سته امتار بدءا من اليوم حتى
الاثنين المقبل من جهه اعلنا المركز
الوطني للارصاد السعودي ان الحاله
المداريه في بحر العرب لا يوجد لها اي
تاثير مباشر على الاجواب في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
من مسقط ينضم الينا اخصائي الارصاد الجويه
بالطيران المدني محمد المدحاني سيد محمد
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه ما الذي
يمكن ان نعرفه اولا عن هذا الاعصار بيبر
جوي ما هو هذا الاعصار وهل وصل فعلا الى
عمان في هذه اللحظات
مرحبا بكم وفي المستمعين الكرام
طبعا هنا من المركز الوطني للاداره المبكر
ولا من المخاطر المتعدده في سلطنه عمان تم
اصدار تقرير رقم ثلاثه باخر التحديثات
للحاله المداريه حيث تشير اخر صور الاقمار
الاصطناعيه الى كمركز الاعصار المداري من
الدرجه الاولى وسط بحر العرب الموقع
الحالي هو على خط طول
66.4 شرقا ودائره عرض
14.8 شمالا وتوصل سرعه الرياح حول المركز
حوالي 64 الى 70 عقده ويبعد مركز الاعصار
عن عن سواحل سلطنه عمان حوالي 1020 كيلو
متر ويتحرك باتجاه الشمال بسرعه تبلغ
من خمسه الى سبعه كيلو متر في الساعه
وتبعد اقرب كتله سحب ماطره حوالي 630 كلم
ولا يزال اعصار مداري من الدرجه الاولى
متى من المتوقع ان يصل الى عمان اذا او
تتاثر به الاجواء العمانيه
مباشره على سواحل السلطنه خلال ثلاثه
الايام القادمه كما تشير ايضا النماذج
العدديه الى احتماليه ضئيله باتجاه الحاله
المداريه الى سواحل السلطنه هل سبق وان
ضربت هذه الحاله المداريه او مرت بعمان
خلال السنوات الماضيه
خلال سنه الماضيه هناك عده حالات غير هذه
الحاله حاله
صار المداري اطلق عليه لانه تكون في بحر
العرب هذه الفتره هناك عده اعاصير اخرى
حدثت نعم اثرت على سواحل السلطان طيب
تاثيراته كم ستستمر او هل هناك مثلا يعني
تاثيرات سباقيه متوقعه من قبلكم في
الارصاد الجويه
حاليا لا
توجد اي سواحل السلطنه
مباشره وهي تدفق السحب العاليه على سواحل
المطله لبحر العرب كذلك حاله البحر قد
يكون البحر سوف يكون البحر هائج الموت على
سواحل بحر بحر العرب المطله على سواحل
الامانيه المطله على بحر العرب قد يرتفع
الموج الى من ثلاثه الى خمسه امتار من
مسائل يوم الجمعه خلال ثلاثه ايام القادمه
طيب ارتفاع موجه البحري الى سته امتار
يعني ليس من خطوره هذا الامر اليوم الاحد
اليس خطيرا هذا الامر على السواحل
العمانيه
نعم كذلك بهذا السبب ندعو المواطنين
المواطنين والمقيمين الى اخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم ارتياد البحر خلال ثلاثه ايام
القادمه وعلى اخذ المعلومات من المصادر
الصحيحه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من مسقط اخصائي
الارصاد الجويه بالطيران المدني محمد
المدحاني شكرا لك
سته الاف وست مئه مقعد نصيبه حجاجي
فلسطيني من حج هذا العام يستعدون هذه
الايام لمغادره الى مكه المكرمه وبدء
مناسك الحج بعد اسابيع زميل خالد القاسم
عايش بعضا من الحجاج في جنين استعداداتهم
للحد نتابع
[موسيقى]
ان الحمد
والنعمه لا والملك لا شريك لك لبيك فايز
ورسميه محاطاني بابناء العائله لوضع
اللمسات الاخيره ما قبل السفر الى الديار
الحجازيه لاداء مناسك الحج حيث يرتباني ما
يجب اصطحابه الى السعوديه من مواد غذائيه
بسيطه وغير قابله للتلف ولن شعور فرح قوي
ستير والله ليله ما طلعت
واحنا قاعدين
فرحتنا كبيره يعني خمس سنين وانا اسجل من
خمس سنين وما تطلعش غير الخامس طلع
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني لعنا ولد نفرح
فيه بنت نفرح فيها الحمد لله رب العالمين
طلعت لنا الحجه احسن من كل شيء
ابو يوسف وزوجته جهز مسبقا هدايا لتقديمها
لكل شخص يحضر لتهنئتهما بالحج وبالعوده
بالسلامه وترك هدايا اخرى لاحضارها من
الحجاز لعدم توفرها في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
والله اكثر من 20 يوم
اعطينا
لها كلفتنا بحدود ال 2000 دينار تقريبا
الهدايا
بعدها
عشان يعني انبسطت يعني بدي ابسط انها مجوز
يعني ولد الحجه وابسط العالم زي ما بقوا
يجيبوا لي جبت لهم للحجه سته الاف وستمئه
فلسطيني سيزورون الاراضي الحجازيه هذا
العام منهم ابو يوسف وام يوسف بعد خمسه
اعوام من المحاولات للظفر بالفرصه حيث
ستكون مغادره الحجاج عبر الاردن على ثلاث
دفعات بعد اخذ الطعومات اللازمه والوثائق
الضروريه
من بلده العصعصه شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
خالد القاسم العربيه
احبطت هيئه الزكاه والجمارك السعوديه
محاولتي تهريب اكثر من 450 الف حبه
كبتاجون عثر عليها مخبا في اجزاء شاحنات
قادمه الى منفذ الحديث الجمارك اوضحت في
بعين لها انه بعد اتمام عمليات الضبط جرت
تنسيق مع المديريه العامه لمكافحه
المخدرات لضمان القبض على مستقبل
المضغوطات داخل السعوديه وهما شخصان اتخذت
بحقهم الاجراءات النظاميه
في قرار هو الاول من نوعه اصدرت وزاره
الرياضه قرارا بتكليف حنان القرشي رئيسا
لنادي وجه الرياضي بالطائف ذلك بعد حلم
لسداره النادي واكد حساب نادي عبر تويتر
انه جرى تكليف حنان القرشي برئاسه مجلس
اداره نادي ويتش وترشيح اعضاء المجلس
المؤقت هذا وشارك النادي في دوري الامير
محمد بن سلمان للدرجه الاولى في عام 2017
بعد ان صعد من انديه الدرجه الثالثه ثم
صعد الى انديه الدرجه الثانيه ومنها الى
الاولى
تنضم الينا من الطائف رئيسه نادي ويتش
حنان القرشي حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض الف مبروك اولا اول
امراه سعوديه تراس نادي رياضي وخليني اسال
اولا عن اللي دفعك للقبول بهذا التكليف
هذا المنصب وهذه الاولويه انجاز التعبير
مرحبا وحياكم جميعا
الله يبارك فيك ان شاء الله
والله شوف اولا واخيرا كل دوافعنا هي تظل
هي حب لهذا البلد المعطى حب لقيادتنا
الجميله حب للنجاح حب للرياضه
حب انه يكون في كل مجالات البلد هذا اللي
يحتاج منا هذه الوقفه وهذا النجاحات وهذا
العطاء
فلو سالتني هذا السؤال يكون هناك الكثير
من الكلمات التي تعبر عن هذا الشيء ممتاز
على مستوى الرياضي
يعني ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمينه تقدمينه
لنادي وجه انت وباقي اعضاء مجلس الاداره
اللي طبعا يكتمل مجلس الاداره خلال الايام
القادمه اسال عن الاهداف الان اللي قدام
عينك
المجال الرياضي مجال جميل وفي نفس الوقت
هو صعب يحتاج الكثير من الاداره الحكيمه
من الامور الماليه الجيده التي تدعم
وترفعوا حكومتنا ما قصرت ولاه الامر ما
قصروا علينا دعم سخي جدا
لكن نسال الله التوفيق والسداد بالاداره
الجيده بالاعضاء الجيدين لكي نحقق النجاح
المامون والمطمح له باذن الله ممتاز وش
اهم الاهداف اليوم على خارطه حنان قرشي في
رئاستها والله باذن الله باذن الله حاعمل
جاهده اننا نوصل للدرجه الاولى لدوري
الممتاز لروشين طموح كبير لكن باذن الله
نحاول نوصله بوقفه اهالي الطائف الطيبين
الكرماء المعطائيين سمو المحافظ
دولتنا وقيادتنا ما قصرت معانا وان شاء
الله النجاح باذن الله يكون قريب انت
عارفه انه المجال الرياضي ومجال يمكن شوي
صعب في التعامل
الضغوطات ايضا بشكل بشكل كبير ويمكن انت
شفتيه خلال المواسم اللي راحت كل ما زادت
حده التنافس والتحدي في الموسم الاعلام
ايضا حتى كذلك مهم كبير من هالمساله هل
انت مستعده لهذه المغامره
والله بلدنا يستحق الا يستحق هذا البلد
لمن غامق لمن غامر عشانه انا انا اسالك
نقول يا رب نقول يا رب الله معنا والتوفيق
بيد رب العالمين اهي محاوله للنجاح
النجاحنا في الخير ان شاء الله
لنا وللجميع وانت فشلنا نقول في هذا من
انفسنا وليس من الاخرين يعني في النهايه
هو اجتهاد اتمنى اتمنى فعلا اني
موجود في الدوري الدرجه الثانيه
يحتاج صفقات كثيره يحتاج اللاعبين ايضا
يعني على على قدر كبير من خلينا نقول
المهاره وعلى قدر ايضا كبير حتى من
المسؤوليه وهذه كلها تحتاج للملاء ماليه
اللي هي هذه موجوده اليوم في نادي ويتش
موجود عند حنان القرشي او كيف حتوفر
ليست موجوده بمعنى موجوده ولكن موجود اللي
ان شاء الله يساعد نحتاج الكثير
بنحاول نوجد هذا الكثير
على قدر ما نستطيع
الامن موجود يظل الامل موجود بالعمل على
ايجاد مصادر ماليه للنادي باذن الله احنا
شغالين على هذا باذن الله احنا شغالين على
هذا النقطه ويدوب يعني الموضوع ما حصل له
يومين لكن نحاول نجتهد ونلحق على قولتهم
اللي نقدر نلحق عليه يا رب
يكونوا في دوري الدرجه الاولى يا رب باذن
الله باذن الله حامل جاهده اننا نكون في
الدوري الدرجه الاولى بمشيئه حيكون في
عظام اعظام الاداره سيدات
باذن الله هذه المره انا حريصه جدا
وحتكوني حريصه برضو على الرياضات النسائيه
وتفعيلها وتكون اكثر يعني والله انا مسبقا
كنت احد الاعضاء الموجودين بالنادي هنائبه
الرئيس والرئيس التنفيذي برضو للنادي
فتقريبا الى حد ما كل همي واهتمامي هي كره
القدم حاليا الالعاب المختلفه ثانيا حريصه
جدا على مجال السيدات واني انا ارتقي فيه
بلدنا تستاهل تستاهل
بالتوفيق ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك من
الطائف رئيسه
اوضاعنا انسانيه صعبه يعيشها السودان حيث
ازدادت اعداد الوفيات بين الاطفال في دور
الايتام بسبب سوء التغذيه والجفاف ما دفع
اليونيسف لاجلاء حوالي 300 منهم
هنا باختصار رضاع يناشدون على طريقتهم
امبارح هم لا يدركون لكن ثمه تداعيات حرب
حاضره فوق رؤوسهم وفي امعائهم ايضا
اطفال توفوا جوعا في الخرطوم رصه الجثث
تباعا خلال الشهرين الماضيين سبعون يتيما
رضيعا واطفال اكبر سنا لم يقاوموا تداعيات
الجوع اكثر
ايتام في دور اخرى محظوظون قوافل للامم
المتحده جاءت لاجلائهم شيء من السكينه
للاطفال وللعاملون ايضا
نحن سعداء حقا اننا استطعنا تنفيذ هذا
الاجلاء ويمكننا كمنظمه محايده تنفيذ
عمليات اخرى استطعنا الحصول على جميع
الضمانات الامنيه
اجلاء تحقق بنجاح لكن الاطفال لم تتاثر
اجسادهم فقط بل يعانون من امراض عقليه
ونفسيه جراء الحرب
كان من المحزن حقا ان نرى كل هؤلاء
الاطفال يعاني بعضهم من حاله صحيه عقليه
وحالات صحيه اخرى
تسارعت عمليات الانقاذ بعد ارتفاع معدلات
الوفيات حالتين الى اربع يوميا فيما توفي
50 طفلا وعشرون رضيعا منهم 13 توفوا دفعه
واحده في السادس والعشرين من مايو الماضي
اطفال وان قاوموا يواجهون الان مستشفيات
خاويه لا ترعى غذاء السالم العربيه
اضرت لقطات جويه تصاعد اعمده الدخان
الناجم عن حريق ضخم في احد الغابات غربي
كندا حيث تشهد كندا اسوا بدايه لموسم
حرائق الغابات على الاطلاق الامر الذي دفع
الاف السكان لترك منازله
[موسيقى]
ختام رابعه بابرز عناوينها
الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن التواصل الاتفاق
يوقف النار في السودان لاربع وعشرين ساعه
بدايه من صباح الغد
كاتب امريكي ايراني يدعو واشنطن لفهم ولي
العهد السعودي وبدء مرحله جديده مع الرياض
رحله السعوديه نحو الثوره الصناعيه
الرابعه تستمر تقييم مئه مصنع وتضاعف
اعداد العاملين
تراقب لاعصار جديد على سواحل عمان
وتحذيراته من تاثيرات التي قد تمتد لاربعه
ايام قادمه
وحنان القرشي تتراس في محافظه الطائف اول
سيده سعوديه تتولى رئاسه نادي رياضي
رابعا تاج شكرا لكم على كرامي ولطف
المتابعه في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات